thank you very much for being with us
and before we kind of dive into the
complexities at the trade talks
I'm just keen to ask you about a story
on the front page of them on Sunday
today which claims were seen leaked
emails from a Treasury adviser
suggesting that actually Britain doesn't
need farmers at all that we could just
import our food follow the example of
Singapore which is rich without having
its own agricultural sector so do we
need farmers well look I haven't seen
the piece I've only seen bits and pieces
on social media but I think you know
there the reference to comparing Britain
with Singapore I mean Singapore has 5
million people and doesn't have any
farmed landscape so it actually has to
import all its food whereas of course
here 75% of Britain is a farmed
landscape we have a fantastic maritime
climate in which to produce our food and
of course we have 60 plus million people
here to feed so there is a sort of moral
imperative if you like for us to be able
to produce food here in this country so
absolutely we need our farmers and of
course we're the bedrock of the largest
manufacturing sector providing all those
those raw ingredients and currently
Sophie at 60% self-sufficiency at the
same time you say there's a moral
imperative but is there a cold-hearted
economic case to say that actually
farming is new a relatively small amount
of GDP why should farmers be given tax
breaks when we could import food well
clearly there is a sort of as you say a
cold economic case but look I think you
have to look at the wider aspect of all
of this you know farms are the backbone
of rural Britain the Allied trade those
jobs that are linked to farming and as I
say were the largest manufacturing
sector surely the last thing we want to
go to is importing cheaper raw
ingredients produced to lower standards
we export our conscience and our
production and with climate change and
everything else you know I've set the
pitch set the agenda that we want to be
global leaders in climate friendly
farming there's a real opportunity for
this government to lead based on
standards and integrity and actually
putting farmers at the forefront of
delivering on climate change so we have
to see this as a knob
Trinity and comparisons with Singapore
are just completely out of touch with
where this country is given these emails
the UK of course about to go into some
reintroduce with the EU but also of
course with the US are you a bit worried
that farmers could be about to be sold
down the river here look of course we're
concerned I've been talking about
nothing else you know for the last three
years
it is absolutely paramount that we get
trade right we've asked for legislation
in the agriculture bill we've asked for
a commission really to scrutinize these
trade deals and to provide our offer for
what agri-food is going to be on the
world stage we haven't had answers to
any of those yet we still you were
interviewing George just as last weekend
this is still being discussed we await
the publication of the objectives but it
is absolutely fundamental that we do not
open up our borders effectively to cheap
raw ingredients that would be illegal to
produce here the British consumer really
values animal welfare and environmental
protection as well as food safety so
those imports have to meet the same
standards that we have here which is why
we feel we need the Commission and the
legislation in the agriculture bill
let's talk about those standards in
particular and because last month the
previous Environment Secretary Theresa
Villiers said that we won't be importing
chlorinated chicken or hormone treated
beef from the United States and you
reference my interview of George Eustace
last weekend who's taken over that brief
he said that those things are currently
illegal and the government has no plans
to change that I mean do you get a sense
that the position on things like hormone
treated beef chlorinated Trickett
chicken has been relaxing or softening
slightly look I've always seen it as you
know a negotiation if you like here you
know it's clear the people of this
country want to maintain the standards
that we have the farmers want to
maintain the standards that we have the
environmentalists want to maintain that
there is a royal shared belief well
there are many I said at our conference
last week you know this is a moral
purrs test for some in government you
know we know that not everybody in
government values that but I will
continue to make the case it is the
right thing to do and and we talked
about chlorinated chicken it's actually
not about the chlorination of chicken
that is perfectly safe to eat it's about
the production methods that sit behind
that and you know here we we have rules
we have legislation on stocking density
on veterinary advice on bedding on light
in other countries they do not have any
of those rules any of that legislation
in many countries across the world
indeed a lot of them with feedlot
systems prophylactic feeding of
antibiotics to act as a growth stimulant
we banned all of that here 30 years ago
so why would we want to go back there
this surely is the chance to lead beyond
the world stage driving standards and
integrity forwards not going back to the
dark ages undermining our farmers and
ultimately putting them out of business
I don't think anybody in government
wants to see that happen and you
mentioned there the moral compass of
some in government and an interview with
Politico earlier this week you suggested
that George Eustace might not willed
quite the same Authority perhaps or
influence as someone like Michael Gove I
don't doubt his sincerity but this is
heavyweight political discussions it
will be testing the moral compass of son
are you confident that the current
environment secretary has got the clout
to protect farmers as you'd see it when
the going gets tough look Georgie says
absolutely understands his brief inside
out he's been in the department since
2013 he's a passionate advocate of
British farming but this is you know
whoever is in his job has the same
challenge this approach has to be
hardwired across government so you know
this cannot sit with any one man indeed
any one department this has to
absolutely come from the top be
hardwired across government and every
department has to be bought into that
ambition when you last on the show and
during the conservative leadership
campaign last summer you said that you'd
written to Boris Johnson and about
consent of a nodal Brixton had heard
anything back I'm just wondering you
were saying it looked bit early that you
haven't had answers on everything from
the government has communication
proved with number Turner you having
meetings with ministers look we're
meeting regularly with different
ministers and I met with Liz trust the
Department of International Trade not
that long ago I haven't had the chance
to meet the Prime Minister yet we have
written it would be I think a
much-needed meeting to discuss the
opportunity in all of this I think we
spend a lot of time discussing the
negative aspect I really do you think
there is an enormous opportunity for
Britain to lead on the world stage the
WTO is bereft of leadership at the
moment but we have to make sure that for
my sector those those values if you like
that we hold so dear are embedded in
trade deals and of course you know we
face the prospect of a No Deal situation
if we can't agree the EU relationship we
can't agree trade deals before next
January we are back into the No Deal
prospect so you know we have to get this
right we absolutely have to make sure we
prioritize the EU relationship and I
other thing there's a huge opportunity
once we've done that with the bilateral
with the US and indeed other trade
agreements across the world okay and
just finally flooding and still of
course the affecting large parts of the
country many farms impacted are you
getting enough support look I can't tell
you how bad this is
you know we've got a third of the
country that is under water we've got
very little planting done there's been
communities rural communities urban
communities flooded we feel that farmers
are the solution in all this we
published a flood manifesto in 2012 we
re launched it again in 2016 nothing has
changed you know we are going to have to
invest in our water infrastructure
there's a great opportunity for us to be
able to store water so we pay farmers to
store water and then potentially we can
move it which the English water
companies are down talking about we can
move it to areas where we need it most
in the drier months of the year and of
course use it for irrigation
once it's stored you know we are
importing a vast amount of our fruit and
vegetables we only produce seven percent
of our fruit here there's a fantastic
opportunity for us to produce much more
fruit here and we have the water we have
a bountiful supply of
we are sourcing that fruit and vege from
from water scarce parts of the country
so I think this is an opportunity to
have a major reset on water
infrastructure and of course climate
change constantly changing weather
events more extreme we've got to do it
we've got to bite the bullet and invest
in our water infrastructure ok minute
batter's thank you very much for coming
the program this morning thank you